Cobra what's your ideal woman well first
of all of age
alive
cisgendered consenting
I like that has to even be stated of age
alive consenting
cisgender Chastity you're not open to no
cisgender
they've got cisgendered
non-related you said non-related
all those good points are those points
are valid
all those all those points
all those points are valid that's facts
some of you are right now watching our
videos alongside with your cousin and
they also your significant other
Hey listen incestors incest ain't that
what they say let's go
at least a four or above only good looks
scale like if she's a six on her best
day you know kind of thing
preferably someone who is 21 and up
oh four on the look scale that is
someone
I appreciate him hey
my man actually knows how to rate out of
10.
because I
go ahead preach because I gotta reint
afterwards I appreciate him I appreciate
him
where he stands and he knows where he's
going maybe it's General but up to now
there was nothing that was outlandish in
what he said there was nothing that was
out of place there was nothing that was
out there like it was like this is
unattainable it was like no you know
I'ma name those things but that's what I
want and
a lot of people out there or not aware
and are not as concise as this dude
right here she's so I'm not mad at that
oh this is a personal Pet People mine I
don't know why we have an out of 10
scale for you A five is a zero then just
do it out of five I'm so sick of Ty be
like oh they're ugly they're a five out
of ten no [__] that's average
that's average the reason why I like
what this guy says he's at a four he
said listen she can be a bit on the
butter side but if she tries a little
bit she's a little bit above average yay
that's a reasonable scale
because I want to ask me what's a two
out of 10 to you
give us two out of tens there's some
zeros too Stephen Hawk yay got rest in
peace
that's that's a zero there's some ones
out there twos threes but nobody ever
want to say that everybody you ask them
oh what are you and if they want to say
average you know what their number is
seven
seven is at no seven is zero
for some people five Z five is below
zero yay six is zero
seven is average eight is ugly
everybody's a nine
their skills don't make no goddamn sense
of y'all that's your scale no a zero and
zero zero and a four is okay he said I
want a four I appreciate this month uh
four shout outs to you man you looked in
the mirror he said you deserve a four
but I would still take you neither you
deserve a four he that means that he is
aware of the scale of the world and you
know the worst part about this all Dean
most of y'all looked at this guy said
yeah four makes sense
because he's aware someone else out here
look delusional this guy is most he's
more aware than a lot of you out there
yeah
shout outs to you okay I use th H
Handley he don't know what to do and
it's a bit overwhelming I understand
that I would suggest you to buy the
level one box which comes with all the
basics a daily face watch which gets rid
of all the dirt and Grime on your face
they got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and they're going to be able to give
you all the instruction in order for you
to have a good skin care for you to be
looking all Flawless yeah because that's
your money maker that's the first thing
that people see when they see you your
face that's right and you got to take
care of it if you click on the link
below you will not only save 30 off your
first box but you will also receive a
gift get it it's uncomplicated skin care
routine for men that's what I use look
at this flawless that shit's nice
compared to this morning you could do a
before and after hmm
someone said I could never get with a
man who said you want to get with a four
and then try to get with me he said if
she a four she better know
because ain't nobody want to be with an
ugly person who don't know that
he's a 10. yeah that's a whole lot of
problems nah you're four you think
you're four clap your hands there you go
if you're four you think you're a four
clap your hands you could realistically
did an 18 year old because it's legal
but yeah it's not as fun because you
can't take him out for a drink all right
[Music]
facts
oh I like that oh I like that I do
I said he said I'm about to get yucky
with a girl
[Music]
yay
people without that beer off camera
brother said you know how we do it this
is how we do we we drink it yay shout
outs to him a bunch of Europeans are
watching like 21 wait y'all can't drink
at 18 not in America they can't no in
Canada you can not in British Columbia
it's 19 but uh the rest of us is 18.
yeah I don't know there's I don't think
there's anything else to say with this
guy and why did what are people saying
about this guy what do they say he ain't
asking for a lot healthy taste in women
let them cook has to be alive 100 agree
yes everybody's agreeing with this dude
hey I'm
some of you some of you are already you
know I mean some of you might need to
take a page out of this book shout out
to stay happy seems to be doing okay for
himself yeah live your life get good for
him you know cheers somebody I need to
take a look in the mirror and say oh man
maybe I only deserve before and maybe
you need to do some things to improve
but if you don't maybe you need to be
looking at some Force that's okay
pussy's [__] dick is Dick there's some
ugly dudes out there who are hung and
can string you along I mean they could
they could take care of things and
there's some Butters women out there who
cook clean got good jobs pay some bills
support a very nice kind and Andy yeah
it was like listen the end of the day
companionship can come in the form of an
ugly person or an attractive person but
ugly people also got great qualities you
know what I'm saying if you ugly and you
mean ugly person go be happy go find
some love just don't post them on
Instagram
all my ex is mad right now shut up ugly
go look in the mirror you're a four two
stupid
[Laughter]
them standards you know I'm saying take
a mirror this guy is a glass actor ask
some strangers yeah what do I deserve
you won't figure it out this guy is a
Class Act live your life God damn man
I'm a four I could cook clean and I did
I deserve a seven listen lady you're a
four in terms of looks just stay at your
level it's all good
I'm just playing Hey listen you know in
spirit of the American Spirit [__]
hustle go for your dreams you deserve a
10 out of 10 girlfriend
get him guys get yourself an IG Baddie
fattest booty biggest lips nice you
deserve all this [__]
work for it if you work hard enough
you're gonna get it because this is
America and a country boy is good enough
for me
anything else you want to say oh no all
right well that's it for us for today's
video let us know what you kings and
queens deserve in the comments below we
want to hear from y'all oh my dude